this video is made possible by nord VPN
a virtual private network service that
gives you the freedom and peace of mind
to browse the internet safely
the toughness of the things was almost
incredible even a terrific pressure of a
deeper sea-bottoms appeared powerless to
harm them
very few seemed to die at all except for
violence when their burial places were
very limited that is a description given
by l'a frosh himself when discussing an
elder thing so far we've covered most of
the major races and species in La Crosse
mythos bar maybe one or two so in
today's video we'll be taking a look at
the elder things the elder things were
considered the first alien race to have
inhabited the earth colonizing the
planet over a billion years ago bluff
graph described them as being six foot
tall incredibly strange creatures of an
oval-shaped body and starfish like
appendages at both ends they possess
characteristics that you would expect
from an animal but also plants and
vegetation at the very bottom of their
bodies we see a five limbed appendage
which like many things in la crosse
mythos resembles tentacles and we can
assume that these were their primary way
of movement though given their science
it's hard to imagine they moved
particularly quickly at the very top of
their body is another appendage where
their numerous eyes and feeding tubes
can be located and these certainly add
to the plot like imagery that surrounds
the other things they also have a set of
retractable wings that can be used for
general flight as well as drifting and
sailing through the ether despite an
appearance that doesn't look like it
represents a vast amount of intelligence
the elder things did possess a
five-lobed brain so they definitely were
quite an advanced thinking species and
we do briefly see this in la crosse
novella in at the mountains of madness
where he describes him as possessing
highly advanced technology though due to
how naturally resilient they were they
found little use for most of it another
interesting fact about the older things
is that they reproduced through the
distribution of spores when this in
itself isn't particularly strange in
lava cross universe and you can
potentially read this as Lovecraft think
in these races had advanced past the
need for intercourse or this may have
something to do with the fact that
Lovecraft himself was quite an awkward
and sheltered person who most likely
wasn't too experienced and had little to
no interest in things like sexual
intercourse which is why so many of the
beings that he writes about just sort of
multiplied and reproduced through other
means the ones that do happen to
reproduce for intercourse often do so of
humans creating quite grotesque hybrids
or even abominations in love cross eyes
some of this may definitely come down to
love crafts irrational fear of race
Nixon because of theories at the time
they claimed the mixing of races caused
mental illness by the late 19th and
early 20th centuries were full of bats
- that made wild and outlandish claims
with little no scientific backing which
ultimately led to many things been
misdiagnosed the other things first made
an appearance in love cross novella at
the mountains of madness written in 1931
and later published in 1936 we learn a
small amount about how they may have
looked and it's hinted that they possess
some kind of energy based weaponry as
well as been experts in genetic
engineering playing a large role in our
own existence
the earliest ancestral forms of
everything living on earth were in fact
created by the older things though their
reasons for developing these life forms
have been heavily debated many argue
that these life forms were created and
bred for them to feed on as they were
thought to be carnivorous in nature
they're also theories where humanity was
created for its psychic potential that
the older things would harvest in the
near future the older things even
created their own slave race known as
the shoggoths
who they brutally murdered when they
attempted to rebel against their masters
when the older things lost city in
Antarctica was eventually discovered
there were carvings that showed they
possess an understanding of physics and
cosmology equivalent to mankind in a
20th century these carvings are likely
millions if not billions of years old to
give you an idea of how advanced their
other things were when compared to
humanity so how exactly did the older
thing survive all of those years on
earth well as we mentioned earlier
they're extremely robust exterior meant
that they weren't really affected by
extreme heat and even the pressures at
the depths of the ocean had no real
effect making them extremely versatile
versatile enough that they could live
anywhere in the earth that they pleased
they were also capable of hibernating
for extremely long periods of time and
because of how tough they were there was
no real threat from predators however
been the first alien race on our planet
meant that they went to war several
times of the other species including the
great race of year the MIGO and the star
spawn of Cthulhu despite all of these
different Wars and confrontations
ironically enough the only enemy that
could not defeat would be the Ice Age
unable to deal with the steep drop in
temperatures they fled to their undersea
cities and began to hibernate and there
they would remain defeated but not
destroyed so lastly many of you may be
wondering what the relationship was like
between the elder things and the great
old ones and honestly we don't really
know much except for the fact that they
were enemies it's hard to call either
side good or bad but the fact that they
were enemies shows us that even if we
are incapable of understanding what
these alien species wanted there's a
good chance they didn't see eye to eye
or even share the same plan for Humanity
the older things were essentially an
extremely tough race of aliens that
helped shape the earth and all life on
it but we don't really know much about
them and I guess that does fit the trope
of the mysterious creator the maker that
we never get to meet out of all the
alien races mentioned by Lovecraft the
older things are certainly amongst the
most popular my parenting countless
stories had followed so let me know what
you think about the other things in the
comments below had you previously heard
of them or have you seen them in any
other form of media the older things may
not have been around during the time of
VPNs but if they were there most likely
would have told you to use one with
companies and individuals attempting to
track everything we watch buy and listen
to Internet privacy has never been so
important so how does one stop this from
happening well the simplest ways to use
a VPN and this is where Nord VPN comes
in with over 5100 servers in 62
different countries you can access their
service from pretty much anywhere in the
world and you can even connect up to six
devices with just one subscription not
only does not VPN not log your data but
it comes with unlimited bandwidth and
peer-to-peer sharing and it's highly
recommended by PC Mag and VPN mentor
websites are clearly know more about
this than I do it's hard to put a price
on keeping yourself and your family safe
when browsing the Internet but nor do
VPN is great value for money and if you
use my coupon code MFE you'll get
yourself a whopping 75% discount meaning
that node VPN will cost Schuessler to us
$2.99 a month and with my coupon code
you even get one month completely free
so check out Nord VPN using the links in
the description and use the code MFE to
keep yourself safe online at a price
that you can afford as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained